all
right we're back we're back I hope so
here we are in America where just days
ago the streets were filled with gleeful
extremists who somehow aren't considered
extremists by our own government as they
cheer the rape and murder of innocent
women and as Israel responds to the
atrocity the people cheering over the
death of Innocents will then shriek over
the death of a new set of Innocents the
ones Hamas uses as human Shields so as
Israel goes to war we're about to
experience a propaganda War here at home
courtesy of the left and their media
marionet msnbc's ratings have already
slid 33% since the terror attack which
means 2third think it's okay before the
Jewish dead were counted you knew it was
coming the excuses for Hamas killing
people in their homes kidnapping young
women and children and filming them
being abused all followed the same
format as the excuse excuses for
criminality here in the US it's the
fault of that old Lefty Chestnut the
oppressor and here you thought I was
going to say climate
change the gist the oppressed can take a
free horrifying cowardly Sucker Punch at
whoever the left has designated the bad
guy it's why they advertise their
barbarism it's no war crime to them it's
an achievement you know like graduating
with honors and atrocity studies the
left of course called for an immediate
ceasefire but there was a ceasefire
already on October 6th but even our
secretary of state called for one and
then he backtracked he then said that
Israel has the right to defend itself
but at the same time the way Israel does
this matters in other words Israel
behave yourself the balls or should I
say lack of balls on this guy is
astounding has any Secretary of State
ever gotten more wrong Afghanistan the
border Israel this guy makes John Kerrey
look like James Madison
no wonder blinkin looks like he's seen a
ghost all of his foreign policy
predictions have gone up in smoke
meanwhile the Squad plays its tune just
take the punch Israel so you know we got
problems when the Ayatollah our
politicians and Academia all sound alike
apparently parading captured young women
naked through the Gaza streets like
trophies doesn't Merit a response the
progressives answer seems regressive
excuse primitive barbarism where rape is
what's for dinner where are the fists
all the grad students dressed up like
handmaid's tail too busy calling January
6 riers terrorists meanwhile actual
killing and raping gets a shoulder shrug
emoji and where are all those celebs who
helped BLM buy some really great
Mansions who are now silent when it
comes to backing Israel remember when
silence was violence now attacking a
music festival isn't but here's the
Western media in a
nutshell all right
nothing to see here please get
first nothing to see here please so you
will start to hear a certain word soon
it's what blinkin was getting at it's
the progressive hbomb in the propaganda
War
proportionality that'll be the term used
to keep Israel from ensuring something
like this doesn't happen again so what
is proportional to these fools write an
angry letter for every 10 babies killed
the goal in war isn't to be proportional
the goal is to win and to make sure you
don't have to go to war again again
there's one side creating atrocities and
another that will actually try to avoid
doing that as it exacts justice for the
initial Mayhem but they don't teach this
at Harvard they don't teach patriotism
either notice there hasn't been one word
from our marching co-eds about the 29
dead Americans maybe more now they must
have lost their voices screaming about
Injustice while taking selfies on phones
made by Chinese
laborers but why do you think that is
because you're an oppressor too America
the left has dehumanized Americans to a
point where crime is now our punishment
our universities have become lunatic
incubators which the federal government
funds they should try registering for
women's studies in the Middle East if
you can get permission from your husband
and so the difference between Israel and
the US is really a matter of degrees the
attack in Israel is a deep fry versus
our slow boil the heat source is the
same the idea of lineage shaming which
means you had it coming sit there and
take it oppressor no wonder we don't
have a border it's oppressive which now
borders on Insanity in the fiscal year
2023 according to DHS 160 migrants whose
names appear on the terror watch list
have already been apprehended by border
agents at this point we're saying you're
a drug mule for a Mexican cartel what a
relief meanwhile crime and disorder Rule
the Day most liberal run cities are like
Gaza but with more Tran addicts we've
had a 40% increase in assaults on women
here in New York alone it's so bad Lady
Liberty is traded in her torch for a
canister of pepper
spray fact is the left has brainwashed
one population into believing the other
population is subhuman based again on
lineage so the oppress gets the free
punch and it goes by many names Dei ESG
restorative justice Equity crime
cashless bail and breaking into an Apple
store to steal bread defeat your
family America's had three years of Hell
while one political party obsesses on
pronouns children's genitals and a green
New Deal whose windmills kill more
whales than Japan so now we see clearly
the monster that the lets created but
will the administration wake up after
all they don't miss a thing well except
massive terrorist attacks so here comes
the great proportionality push which
doesn't help anyone except Harvard
Columbia Stanford Berkeley the New York
Times The Washington Post MSNBC the
squad it allows them to justify their
existence while saying Israel has no
right to its own and it excuses the free
punch from Hamas but the only thing that
should be proportional here the number
of dead Hamas and the number of outof
workor Democrats next year fact is both
America and Israel suffer from an
imbalance Israel needs to regain its
equilibrium by exacting divisive CH
decisive Justice not peace marches
Justice not Revenge Justice and in a way
we need Justice too we have yet to
redress our own Relentless Decay that
slow boil of crime and collapse there is
a voice in your head asking when will
this stop it's a good question still
waiting for an
answer let's
welcome tonight's
guess his commentary gives liberals
dentary Fox News contributor Charles
hurt when it comes to being blunt she
never punts host of the Michelle tooya
podcast Michelle
tooya she's got four eyes three Sports
two kids and one name host of Kennedy
Saves the World podcast
Kennedy and the NYPD uses his act to
disperse large crowds comedian and
co-host of the Jim Norton and Sam Robert
show Jim Norton
M all right we're heading into day 11
Charlie uh what do you see this going
how does it end are you looking ahead or
are you looking at it Moment by moment
it's a lot of questions nice Tie by the
way oh thank you very much I appreciate
that uh no I I loved your monologue and
I love uh your focus on the whole idea
of proportionality because of course
that is sort of the the the way they use
uh it's the the the secret word they use
to punish or curtail
Israel and but but one thing that if
you're at Harvard or wherever you ought
to know enough math to know that you
know for in order to understand
proportionality you have to know what
the entire attack was we don't know what
the entire attack was because we're
still in the middle of the attack you
still have a hundred hostages who are
are are fighting for their lives right
now in tunnels under uh Gaza and so the
idea that we even know what the totality
of it is right now is insane and then
you have leaders of Hamas in cter right
now negotiating with people what this is
insane to me and if if Israel you know
and and I'm glad that that Israel is is
you know doing this we have not
committed to anything but if Israel
wanted to take those people out could
you imagine the leader of a government
going to some foreign Capital to
negotiate about something while they
have hostages at home fearing for their
lives it's insane so you know maybe
proportional is what we're looking for
and if that happens um we still don't
know what the you know where the equ we
can't put the equal sign up yeah yeah
there's the equation isn't set and
Michelle I find the whole idea of
proportionality hilarious because what
is proportional to that Rave right I
mean like could you I mean you'd have to
come up with something so bizarrely
gruesome to be proportional and as civil
human beings we don't do that no we
don't and there is nothing proportional
to what is being suggested was done to
babies because not only are you doing it
to the babies you have wrecked these
moms and these parents you have ruined
them they are soulless now they are
burnt to Pieces inside so what's the
proportionality for that yeah you know I
just don't I don't see it this yeah it's
got to be proportional well why why if
someone's coming after me with a knife I
hope I'm going to shoot them first right
that's not proportional but at least I
protected myself so I I I don't believe
in that idea boy I I'll tell you Greg I
you know how you love your dog Gus but
sometimes you don't like the way he
behaves same with like your kids your
spouse you love them but you don't like
them in that moment I love this country
I love the way our government is built
and the Declaration of Independence and
the and the Constitution but I don't
like us very much right now we're being
really stupid on a lot of levels with
the border with these ridiculous these
people at Harvard and wherever else are
coming out it's disgusting and it's
embarrassing and how dare you bring Gus
into this conversation oh but I know but
he's so he has nothing to do with the
Middle East except for that brief stin
in
Hezbollah you know uh Kennedy I love how
you know as in hamas's existence nobody
ever brings up fairness until you have
to strike back and now everybody's like
no no no we got to have proportionality
here we got to play fair you stand over
there you stand over there you get one
knife you get a pair of
scissors I mean why why aren't we
talking about proportionality of intent
yes you know think about what the what
the intent was in this terrorist attack
it was to hurt and kill and the most
horrific means possible with whatever
tools were at your disposal as many
people as you could in a short amount of
time so if if you were going to have a
proportional response it it would be you
know a war crime the degree to which we
can't even imagine if Israel were to
meet the intentional proportionality of
Hamas uh it is inconceivable and and it
cannot happen and Israel will Express
great restraint in terms of
proportionality and in terms of what
they can do but also if you're looking
at this rationally which is impossible
because you're dealing with irrational
actors don't pick a fight with people
who have bigger and more weapons than
you do and then complain about the
manner in which they respond to your
crimes it's it's so and and by the way I
just have to say I was walking down the
street Saturday night here in New York
City and uh a car drove by with
Palestinian Flags out the side they had
just left the uh the Time Square rally
and a guy walked up behind me screaming
F the Jews F the Jews and I turned
around and I was like you know I'm not
Jewish but I was like in that moment I
was and I was like you want to go right
here and he was like he was like a
Teensy skinny little guy in a backpack
and you know my boyfriend I looked at
him like yeah really do you think that
and and then you know he saw the like
crazy Romanian look in my eyes and he
walked away but anti-Semitism is so real
and this this whole thing has given
people license to be openly anti-semitic
and it's not anti-israel these are
people who hate Jewish people yes mhm
well Jim you love the Jewish people some
say too much yes I've been accused of
just touching and fondling for no reason
whatever I just love you I want to ask
you about the uh is there any excuse
that you can give to like these college
protesters we've all had stupid opinions
but these are like is this a different
type of idiocy no they're they're just
dumb and they've always been dumb and
they always get it wrong it is what it
is it's it's kind of the natur Order of
Things something terrible is going to
happen they're going to say something
stupid we're go how can they be so
stupid and then 20 years from now
they're going to have kids who are going
to be stupider than they were it's kind
of the way it goes and I got to say I I
I think I speak for everyone I I hate
the word proportionality I know it's
hard to say don't like it I've never
heard it until this week you never had a
conversation with someone who said
proportionality like that was a fun chat
no one likes that word and you don't get
to you had a good point you don't get to
punch somebody in the face and then
dictate how they respond like if
somebody punches you once and you punch
them once you're emboldening them to hit
you again but if they punch you once and
you kick them in the balls 30 times
they're not going to be as likely yeah
for instance in a relationship um no no
no seg that's a semicolon not a period
um I have I've been in relationships and
like like where uh I had plans with my
girlfriend and she canceled last minute
so I slept with three of her
friends that taught her yes but you know
you're absolutely right proportionality
is exactly the wrong thing because that
means it would go on forever if you do
this and I do that and you do this and
that do that it goes on forever so you
have to actually be out of proportion
wow I think we just solved everything oh
thank goodness all right let's do some
fun stories up next the endless crudity
of Biden
nudity good job if you'll be in the New
York area and like tickets to see gutf
go to foxnews.com / gutel and click on
the link to join our studio audience hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else